wir hören zum beispiel 100 fälle in köln
bei missbrauch das klingt jetzt erst mal
relativ wenig ist da noch eine große
dunkelziffer zu erwarten
man geht ungefähr bundesweit von über
5000 fälle mit laien aus das sind auch
massive kriminalität dabei aber die
dunkelziffer wird natürlich höher liegen
und jetzt kommt es darauf an wie viele
fälle auf fliegen also auch entdeckt
werden und wie viele selbstanzeigen ich
benutze mal diesen begriff denen gibt es
im steuerrecht wie viele selbstanzeigen
tatsächlich jetzt kommen das heißt die
unternehmen haben festgestellt uns geht
es jetzt gar nicht so schlecht und wir
zahlen das geld zurück das gibt es auch
deswegen wird jetzt abzuwarten sein was
da kommt aber kriminelle energie haben
wir einige erlebt und vor allen dingen
wird interessant sein um wieviel summen
es sich handelt da wird man so einen
zweistelligen millionenbereich zurzeit
schätzen
ich fürchte es ist deutlich höher muss
ihnen da nicht der messer in der tasche
auf gehen das ist hier halt das geld ja
unser geld was wir erwirtschaftet haben
können sie als verband da druck machen
oder sind sie jetzt mit dem zufrieden
wie es jetzt läuft
ich glaube am anfang war es richtig
wirklich schnell und unbürokratisch zu
helfen
aber jetzt sind wir in einer phase wo
eben auch der gerechtigkeit aspekt
wirklich wichtig ist und viele menschen
sagen das ärgert mich massiv ich habe
keine hilfen bekommen oder ich habe sie
sogar zurückgezahlt aber der und
diejenigen die haben das nicht getan und
auf einmal steht ein schicker wagen vor
der tür also da gibt es einiges und das
ist ganz wichtig dass politik dieses
gefühl auch aufgreift denn viele
entscheidungen sind von gerechtigkeit
individuellen gerechtigkeit eindrücken
geprägt und deswegen muss jetzt auch
entschlossen gehandelt werden der der zu
unrecht diese hilfen in anspruch
genommen hat muss auch hart zur kasse
gebeten werden im steuerrecht haben wir
den ausspruch steuerhinterziehung ist
kein kavaliersdelikt und das gilt
genauso für subventionsbetrug denn
nichts anderes ist es am ende müssen wir
uns immer klar werden dass es unser geld
wir müssen dafür schulden aufnehmen und
dieses geld fehlt an anderer stelle
vielleicht für bildung vielleicht für
bessere polizei vielleicht für gute
infrastruktur